Catedrática Tamar Gendler:
Tenemos mucho que hacer
en la clase hoy, pero haremos 2
cosas principalmente.
Primero, terminaremos con la
discusión de las opiniones
de Aristóteles sobre la
felicidad y la armonía,
y después, quiero presentarles el
tema del alma desordenada.
En la segunda parte de la clase
usaremos los clickers.
Asegúrense de tenerlos a la mano
dentro de unos 8 minutos más o menos.
Como recordarán, en la
última clase hablábamos
de la idea antigua de que existe
una especie de desarrollo
al alcance de los seres humanos.
Una especie de prosperidad,
de algo que los griegos
llamaban eudemonismo,
al alcance de las personas
cuyas almas manifiestan
cierto tipo de armonía.
Recodarán que la imagen antigua
presentada por Platón
y adoptada en gran parte
por Aristóteles
era que tenemos razón, racionalidad.
Tenemos espíritu, un
conjunto de emociones
relacionadas con cosas como el honor.
Tenemos apetito, relacionado con cosas
como el consumo de comida
y la procreación que permite que
nuestra especie perdure,
y la procreación por el
gusto de procrear.
La persona que tiene la oportunidad
de desarrollarse o prosperar
es aquella cuyos instintos en
los dominios del apetito
y de las emociones
están en línea con sus
compromisos reflexivos.
Alguien que actúa de forma automática
con reflexión.
La persona que de forma
instintiva se sienta a leer
si se ha comprometido a leer.
La persona que de forma instintiva
rechaza el pastel de chocolate
que se le presenta
y si se ha comprometido a eso.
En el fragmento de Ética a
Nicómaco que leímos,
Aristóteles intenta darnos una
fórmula, una estrategia,
un método para conseguir
un alma ordenada.
Para recordarles cómo encaja esto en
el contexto de su argumento,
Aristóteles afirma que hay una cosa
que buscamos por sí misma
y es precisamente lo que
acabo de mencionar.
Es la prosperidad o el eudemonismo.
El sentimiento de que se vive
siendo el mejor que uno puede ser.
Aristóteles destaca
que el tipo de prosperidad que
interesa en este caso
no es la gratificación que brinda
el satisfacer nuestros
apetitos inferiores.
No es la gratificación
derivada de satisfacer
las demandas que nos hacen el
honor o el espíritu.
Sino la gratificación derivada
de usar nuestra capacidad
de seres pensantes.
Recuerden el argumento que expliqué
al final de la clase pasada:
cada objeto tiene algo especial
y por eso tiene determinadas propiedades
que el resto de los objetos
del mundo no tienen.
Y la función especial de los seres
humanos, según Aristóteles es
la expresión de la razón: "La
actividad del alma que expresa razón"
según una de las traducciones.
El bien del humano, según el
concepto de Aristóteles,
tiene que ser aquello que
distingue a los humanos
de otras criaturas.
Las otras criaturas que tienen
apetitos inferiores
como los que describimos antes.
De hecho, casi todos los seres
biológicos parecen tener
lo que Platón llamaría
la parte apetitiva del alma.
Y parece que cierta cantidad
de animales no humanos
también tienen lo que Platón y
Aristóteles llamarían
la parte animada del alma,
de alguna forma.
Tienen conexiones emocionales
que parecen manifestarse en
su comportamiento.
Pero la mejor y más
característica virtud humana,
según Aristóteles, es la
capacidad de razonar
y reflexionar.
Y la capacidad de estructurar
nuestra vida de tal forma
que el espíritu y el apetito se
alineen con la razón.
La virtud, según Aristóteles,
es aquello en que las respuestas
instintivas se alinean
con los compromisos reflexivos.
Aquello que en los momentos
en que no están poniendo
atención a su comportamiento
si miran atrás para analizarlo piensan:
"Me alegro de haber ayudado a ese niño
en ese momento de crisis".
O "lo que hice me impidió
caer en la tentación
de hacer algo de lo que me
arrepentiría".
La pregunta que preocupa a
Aristóteles, en las páginas que
leímos,
es: ¿Cómo es esa virtud
y cómo podemos cultivarla?
Recuerden que la virtud, es
precisamente aquella
que Platón llamaba la
virtud de la justicia.
La virtud derivada de
cierto tipo de armonía
entre las partes del alma,
la armonía
que nuestra razón aprueba.
Repasaré un poco rápido las
próximas dos diapositivas,
porque retomaremos el tema
de Aristóteles
otras dos veces en las
próximas tres clases.
De muchas maneras, esta unidad del curso
intenta dar una exposición de
las ideas de Aristóteles.
Este es el primer intento
y haremos otros dos.
Aristóteles distingue entre
2 tipos de virtudes:
las del pensamiento y las del carácter.
Las virtudes del
pensamiento son aquellas
que desarrollamos mediante la
enseñanza pedagógica directa.
Es una virtud del
pensamiento saber que
6x7=42.
Es una virtud del pensamiento saber
datos de la tabla periódica
o saber información particular
de las estructuras
políticas a tu alrededor.
Esas son virtudes del pensamiento
y la forma en que se comunican y se
cultivan en otras personas
es mediante el proceso
pedagógico tradicional.
Uno de los temas cruciales de la
tradición filosófica antigua
es que además de las
virtudes del pensamiento
existen las virtudes del
carácter, según Aristóteles.
Las virtudes del carácter
no se procesan de forma racional
ni se adquieren porque
alguien se las enseñe.
Son cosas que se procesan
en las partes animadas y
apetitivas del alma
como resultado de cultivar un hábito.
Aristóteles considera que estas
virtudes del carácter
surgen no por naturaleza pero tampoco
en contra de la naturaleza.
¿Qué quiere decir con esto?
Supongamos que intento
entrenar a mis lentes
para que floten en el aire
cuando los suelte.
¿Tendré éxito?
Podría premiarlos cada vez
que floten en el aire
y regañarlos cada vez que
se caigan al suelo.
No importa cuántas veces intente
entrenar a mis lentes,
se volverán a caer al suelo.
Flotar va en contra de su naturaleza.
Es imposible cambiar la
relación entre mis lentes
y la fuerza gravitacional del mundo.
Aristóteles lo explica con una piedra.
Es imposible cambiar el
carácter de los lentes.
Por el contrario, si tomo una
semilla de calabaza,
la pongo en un poco tierra, la
riego y la pongo en el sol,
aunque yo no intervenga,
la semilla de calabaza germinará y
saldrá un retoño de calabaza
de la tierra y se moverá
hacia la luz del sol
y en algún momento formará
una planta de calabaza.
Si siembro una semilla de calabaza,
por naturaleza se convertirá,
sin mi intervención, en una
planta de calabaza.
Las virtudes del carácter se encuentran
entre lo que hace una semilla de
calabaza al formar una planta
e intentar entrenar a unos
lentes para que floten
a pesar de la gravedad.
No surgen en nosotros por naturaleza,
no crecen de forma natural
como pasa con nuestra estatura
o con nuestro pelo.
Esas son cosas que pasan en el
debido curso de las cosas.
Tampoco están en contra
de la naturaleza.
No son como entrenarnos
para flotar en el aire
o para aguantar despiertos 72 semanas
o para sobrevivir sin comida
durante una década.
Esas cosas estarían en
contra de la naturaleza.
Las virtudes del carácter no surgen
en nosotros por naturaleza
pero tampoco en contra de ella.
Más bien, por naturaleza somos
capaces de adquirirlas.
Son cosas para las que
tenemos capacidad.
Y se completan en nosotros
mediante el hábito.
¿Cómo es el proceso de habituación?
Aristóteles destaca, en una de
las citas más famosas
de Ética a Nicómaco, que aprendemos a
hacer las cosas haciéndolas.
Dice Aristóteles: "Aprendemos un oficio
produciendo el mismo producto
que debemos producir
cuando ya hemos aprendido a hacerlo.
Aprendemos a construir".
¿Cómo?
¿Leyendo un libro que se titule
Cómo construir una casa?
Yo leí algo que se llamaba Cómo
armar una mesa de IKEA
y lo que armé no parecía una mesa.
Mi hijo de 12 años sí armó la mesa,
porque obviamente es un
constructor innato.
Vino y me enseñó cómo armar la mesa.
Así aprendí a armarla.
Me convierto en un constructor
practicando el arte de construir.
Me convierto en un arpista
practicando el arte de tocar el arpa.
¿Cuántos de ustedes tocan
algún instrumento musical?
¿Cuántos aprendieron a tocarlo
leyendo un libro llamado
Cómo tocar al piano,
pero sin tocar nunca las teclas?
¿Nadie?
¿Cuántos aprendieron a tocar
un instrumento musical
practicando?
¿Cuántos aprendieron a ser
pianista, arpista o flautista
tocando el piano, el arpa o la flauta?
Bien.
Aristóteles afirma que la forma
de llegar a ser aquello
que esperamos ser consiste en
actuar como si ya lo fuéramos.
Igual que aprendemos a tocar
el piano tocándolo,
aprendemos a ser justos
haciendo cosas justas.
Aprendemos a tener templanza,
actuando de forma moderada.
Aprendemos a ser valientes
haciendo acciones valientes.
Al principio, adquirimos hábitos
estructurando conscientemente
nuestras vidas para que los
hábitos que queremos cultivar
sean parte de nuestro
repertorio de comportamientos,
después, repetimos esas
conductas varias veces
hasta que no requieran de
nuestra concentración.
Es igual que cualquier habilidad
adquirida en el campo musical,
deportivo o cualquier otro.
Al principio de forma consciente
y después de forma instintiva
hemos aprendido a practicar
un patrón de conducta determinado,
así funciona lo que Aristóteles
llama cultivar una virtud.
Retomaremos este tema en
un par de clases.
Quiero concluir esta sección
presentándoles una de las partes
más famosas de la sección de la
discusión de Aristóteles.
Aristóteles explica que hay
un peligro aquí.
Existe el peligro de aprender
a tocar mal el piano,
porque los malos hábitos,
que cultivan cuando mantienen sus
dedos rectos en vez de curvos,
se arraigan en el comportamiento
igual que los buenos hábitos.
No tenemos un mecanismo para
filtrar automáticamente
y pensar que cuando practiquemos
solo usaremos los buenos
hábitos y no los malos.
Cualquier cosa que practiquen
se volverá una costumbre para ustedes.
Estas acciones de practicar lo
que desean adquirir
"son las fuentes y las causas tanto
del surgimiento de las virtudes
como de su ruina".
Si practican a ser valientes,
se volverán valientes.
Si practican, en el mismo
contexto, a ser cobardes,
la cobardía se inculcará en
sus conductas habituales
de la misma forma.
Aristóteles dice que en
todos estos estados
necesitamos prestar
atención a la posibilidad
de perseguir nuestro objetivo
en exceso o muy poco,
por eso debemos buscar el
famoso punto medio.
Las virtudes de Aristóteles
tienden a arruinarse por el
exceso o por la deficiencia.
Supongamos que se enfrentan
a una situación arriesgada.
Hay 2 extremos equivocados en
los que podrían caer.
Podrían responder con cobardía
o de otra forma que sería temeraria.
Según Aristóteles, entre
estos 2 extremos
se encuentra la virtud de la valentía.
Supongamos que están en una
situación social.
Podrían responder con hostilidad.
O podrían responder siendo zalameros.
Según Aristóteles,
entre ambas opciones
está la virtud de la simpatía.
Supongamos que se enfrentan
a una situación
en la que se les pide algo.
Podrían ser tacaños.
O podrían ser ostentosos en lo que den.
O según la maravillosa traducción
que tenemos de Irwin,
podrían ser espléndidos.
Aquello que se encuentra entre lo
tacaño y lo ostentoso.
Supongamos que están
estudiando para los exámenes
de admisión a la universidad,
podrían ser pusilánimes o vanidosos.
¿Cuál sería el punto medio?
En medio estaría la virtud
de la magnanimidad.
Supongamos que están en una situación
en la que podrían sentir
autodesaprobación o ser
jactanciosos.
Ninguna de ellas es la que necesitamos.
Necesitamos la sinceridad que se
encuentra en el punto medio.
Supongamos que hacen una broma.
Podrían ser desabridos o payasos.
O bien, podrían ser ingeniosos.
Podrían ser buscapleitos.
O podrían ser halagadores, otra vez,
o en el punto medio,
podrían ser simpáticos.
Bueno. Esa la tengo repetida.
La idea general es que
en las virtudes según
Aristóteles hay dos extremos:
uno de deficiencia y otro de exceso,
y entre ellos se encuentra el
famoso punto medio.
Recuerden
que en la famosa pintura de
Rafael que les mostré,
"La escuela de Atenas", Platón
está señalando al cielo,
refiriéndose a las formas y la
mano de Aristóteles
está extendida a la altura de
la mitad de su cuerpo.
Y les dije que eso se ha
interpretado de dos formas.
Una, es que se trata del
rechazo de Aristóteles
a la idea de Platón de las formas;
y la segunda es que a veces se
interpreta como una articulación
personificada de la idea de
Aristóteles del punto medio.
Esta es, para su deleite,
la idea de Aristóteles del punto medio.
Repito que retomaremos este
tema en un par de clases.
Permítanme cerrar esta sección
citando el concepto de Aristóteles
del círculo virtuoso de la
formación de hábitos.
Después de esto vamos a
usar los clickers,
así que sáquenlos si aún
no lo han hecho.
Aristóteles dice:
"Abstenernos de los placeres,
nos permite adquirir templanza".
Y una vez que tenemos templanza
somos más capaces de
abstenernos de los placeres.
Pasa algo similar con la valentía.
Acostumbrarnos a mantenernos firmes
en situaciones aterradoras
nos permite volvernos valientes.
Y una vez que nos hemos vuelto valientes
somos más capaces de
mantenernos firmes.
La conducta practicada se
vuelve un círculo.
Dentro de 3 clases,
leeremos la expresión
contemporánea de esta idea
a través de algo llamado
terapia cognitiva conductual.
Ok.
Así cerramos lo que veíamos en la
clase de la semana pasada.
Quiero presentar y cubrir el tema de hoy
en los 25 min. que nos quedan.
Permítanme darles el desenlace ahora.
El desenlace es:
Recuerden que en las primeras
páginas del Libro II
de La República de Platón,
Glaucón reta a Sócrates, el
personaje de Platón,
afirmando que actuar de forma justa,
de acuerdo con los propios
compromisos reflexivos
y con las normas de la moralidad,
es algo que se hace únicamente
por motivos instrumentales.
No hay nada valioso
intrínsecamente para el alma
ordenada.
La clase de hoy se trata de 2
historias increíbles.
Una es La Iliada y la guerra de Vietnam
a través de los textos
de Jonathan Shay;
la segunda, son los
experimentos de Stanley
Milgram,
hechos en este campus en los 60.
Ambas nos abren una
ventana a cómo sería
la experiencia humana en el
mundo soñado de Glaucón.
Glaucón decía: Queremos
dejarnos llevar libremente
sin tener consecuencias por
nuestras acciones.
Queremos violar las normas
de la moralidad.
Cualquiera lo haría si
tuviera la oportunidad.
Las historias de nos
cuentan Shay y Milgram,
las descripciones que nos dan
sobre la experiencia humana
en esos momentos en que el alma se
comporta como enajenada,
sugieren que Glaucón puede
estar equivocado.
Sugieren que por alguna
razón, parece haber,
al menos en estos dominios,
una necesidad en alguna parte
de los seres humanos
de tener cierta estructura y orden.
Y en la ausencia de esa
estructura y orden,
el mundo parece venirse abajo.
Sin embargo, en esta
clase, quiero comenzar
por mostrarles los tiempos tan
raros en los que viven.
¿Podrían responder a esta pregunta?
Pulsen 1 si han hecho el
servicio militar;
2 si no lo han hecho,
pero planean o esperan hacerlo;
y 3, si no lo han hecho
y no planean ni esperan hacerlo.
Pulsen 1, si han hecho el
servicio militar,
ya sea en Estados Unidos o en
su país de origen;
2, si planean en algún momento cercano
hacer el servicio militar;
y 3, si no tienen ninguna
intención de hacerlo.
Ok.
Veamos los resultados de esto.
Bien.
Parece que el 1% han hecho
el servicio militar.
El 5% tiene planes de hacerlo
y el 94% considera
que nunca lo hará.
Siguiente pregunta.
Piensen en una persona muy cercana
que haya servido en el ejército.
Indiquen si es alguien muy cercano,
como un hermano o un mejor amigo.
Pulsen 1 si es así.
Pulsen 2 si es alguien
relativamente cercano como un
primo,
un amigo de la escuela, algún
compañero de equipo,
una persona con la que se sientan
relativamente cercanos.
O pulsen 3 si es algún otro
compañero de su escuela,
un vecino
o alguien a quien no conocen muy bien.
Veamos los resultados.
Ok.
Casi nadie tiene un hermano
o un mejor amigo en el ejército.
Más o menos la mitad conoce a alguien
que esté en servicio
y casi una tercera parte no tiene a
nadie en su círculo social
inmediato que haya servido
en el ejército.
Veamos a la generación anterior.
Les pregunto solo sobre su padre
porque necesitamos una
relación de 1 a 1.
Si les preguntara por
ambos de sus padres
estaríamos duplicando el
conjunto de muestra.
Pulsen 1 si su padre
sirvió en el ejército
o pulsen 2 en caso contrario.
Ok. Veamos los resultados.
Ustedes son un poco
distintos a sus padres.
Alrededor del 5% han hecho el
servicio o tienen pensado hacerlo.
Alrededor del 20% de sus
padres lo hicieron.
Vamos otra generación más atrás.
Su abuelo paterno, otra vez, porque
necesitamos solo una persona.
Pulsen 1 si sirvió en el ejército
o 2 en caso contrario.
El abuelo paterno.
Es decir, el padre de su padre.
¿Sirvió en el ejército?
Ok.
El 54% sirvieron en el ejército.
Pasamos del 4% en su generación,
al 20% en la generación de sus padres
y al 55% en la generación
de sus abuelos.
Están viviendo en una época muy rara.
La distancia social entre la élite
universitaria estadounidense
y el ejército ahora es
más grande que nunca
en los 200 años de historia
de Estados Unidos.
Y la arquitectura que los rodea
da un testimonio vivo de lo rara
que es esta experiencia.
¿Cuántos reconocen este edificio?
Está como a 6 metros de aquí.
Todos deberían levantar la mano.
¿Cuántos se han
acercado a ver qué es?
Este edificio, como algunos saben,
quienes son guías en los recorridos
de Yale sin duda lo saben,
es el Memorial Hall.
Fue construido en 1901 sin
esta fachada de aquí.
Al acabar la primera guerra mundial,
en la que murieron muchos
socios de Yale,
se construyó esta otra parte.
Arriba están escritas las batallas
de la primera guerra mundial
en las que murieron hombres de Yale.
Abajo hay un ataúd vacío
"en memoria de los hombres de Yale,
que fieles a su tradición,
dieron sus vidas
para que la libertad no
pereciera en la Tierra".
La relación de Yale con la primera
guerra mundial fue muy importante.
Aquí hay un fragmento del
discurso que Henry Simpson
dio en la inauguración del monumento
a los caídos en la guerra que
les acabo de mostrar:
"Tras nuestra entrada en la
guerra y la amplia adopción
del gobierno del principio de
servicio universal, poco a poco,
Yale se convirtió en un campo
de entrenamiento militar
y en una universidad
completamente militarizada.
Sus facultades y laboratorios
destinaron sus recursos
completamente a la guerra
y casi todos los alumnos que quedaban
se convirtieron en miembros
de las Fuerzas Militares
Organizadas de los Estados Unidos.
Yale mantuvo una de las
escuelas de artillería
más importantes de Estados Unidos.
Contaba con una gran unidad de
entrenamiento naval
para oficiales de la Marina.
Aquí se entrenaron oficiales para
los cuerpos de señales.
Los químicos dirigieron recursos
para el servicio de la guerra química.
Se prepararon a doctores y asistentes
para los hospitales militares
y la universidad mantuvo
una unidad completa de un
hospital militar en Francia.
Prácticamente todo el ímpetu de la
educación de esta institución
se lanzó eficazmente a las
escalas de la guerra".
La relación entre las
universidades de élite y el
ejército
en ambas guerras mundiales
era muy distinta
de lo que cualquiera de ustedes
podría encontrarse ahora.
En un esfuerzo por guardar en la memoria
las contribuciones de los
hombres de Yale a la guerra,
se decidió que en el interior de
los muros del Memorial Hall
se pondrían placas con sus
nombres grabados.
Si caminan hacia el edificio Commons,
a su derecha cuando entran,
verán los nombres de los
hombres de Yale
que murieron en la guerra
revolucionaria.
En los dos costados,
están los que murieron en ambos
bandos en la guerra civil,
los que murieron en la guerra
hispano-estadounidense,
los 227 que murieron en la
primera guerra mundial,
los 514 que murieron en la
segunda guerra mundial,
los 22 que murieron en la
guerra de Corea
y los 37 que murieron en la
guerra de Vietnam.
Por qué la relación entre las
instituciones de élite y el ejército
llegó a ser como es hoy depende de
una serie de hechos importantes
y complicados en la historia
de los Estados Unidos.
Basta con decir que la mayor
parte de los alumnos de Yale
y una buena parte del profesorado
consideraba que la guerra de
Vietnam era injusta.
Por esa razón
la mayoría no quiso servir
en el ejército,
y de hecho, su valiente
expresión de oposición
tuvo consecuencias directas en
las vidas de algunos.
Pero la actitud del campus de Yale
hacia la guerra de Vietnam
tal vez se capta mejor en esta
foto de unos manifestantes
usando la imagen de este
lugar que conmemora
a aquellos que pelearon en
una guerra justa
y usándolo como una forma para expresar
que la guerra de Vietnam, en
específico, era injusta.
Para quienes aún no están convencidos
de que la filosofía es importante,
esto fue un debate filosófico
sobre la naturaleza de lo que
permite la justicia.
Independientemente de si alumnos de Yale
lucharon en la guerra de Vietnam o no,
una gran cantidad de
ciudadanos estadounidenses
sí lo hicieron.
El texto que leímos para
hoy de Jonathan Shay
es una lectura muy impactante
de esas experiencias
que yuxtapone citas de la gran
descripción antigua
de la experiencia
subjetiva de la guerra,
del texto fundador de la
tradición literaria occidental,
La Iliada de Homero,
y las experiencias de los
veteranos de Vietnam
con los que trabaja Jonathan Shay
para ayudarlos a enfrentarse
al estrés y al trauma que la
guerra les produjo.
La tesis que Shay plantea en su libro
es que cuando un líder destruye la
legitimidad de la orden moral
del ejército traicionando lo
que él llama témis,
es decir, lo que es correcto,
el orden de las cosas,
la estructura que nos permite
comprender el mundo
como predecible y en orden,
se hiere a los soldados,
pero no físicamente.
Se produce lo que Shay
denomina heridas morales.
Shay propone que estas heridas
morales se presentan en La Iliada
cuando Homero describe las
consecuencias inmediatas y
devastadoras
para Aquiles, primero el
sentimiento de injusticia
porque le arrebataron su
premio de guerra
y después, aquello que Shay llama el
comportamiento enloquecido
derivado de la muerte de
su amigo Patroclo.
Hago una pausa para decirles
que al abordar esto,
estamos quitando importancia
a muchos otros problemas
de esa historia.
¿Por qué está enojado Aquiles?
Está enojado porque la mujer
que había recibido
como premio por la batalla se la
quitaron para dársela a otro hombre.
Supongo, que para muchos de ustedes,
su idea de lo que permite el orden moral
no incluye premios de
guerra de ese tipo.
Hablaremos más de esto cuando
lleguemos a la sección de ética.
¿Cómo interpretamos los estándares
morales que son considerados
como legítimos en un
dominio, pero no en otro?
Por ahora, me gustaría, como
hemos hecho en la mayoría
de los textos antiguos que hemos leído,
que pusieran entre paréntesis las
situaciones que consideran
poco familiares y que se enfoquen en
lo que consideren familiar.
La descripción de la experiencia
de Aquiles suena verdadera,
igual que suenan verdaderas
las experiencias
de los soldados de Vietnam.
Shay destaca que igual que La Iliada
es una historia de
consecuencias devastadoras
para Aquiles y para los otros soldados,
lo mismo pasa con los relatos de
los soldados de Vietnam,
son ejemplos que nos obligan a ver
que las consecuencias van más allá.
Una cita de La Iliada dice: "la
pérdida de la guerra por encima
de la amarga pérdida, es dejar a
tantos hombres muertos",
la consecuencia es mancillar las
vidas de los sobrevivientes.
Uno de los principales daños que
parece haber dejado la guerra
de Vietnam a una gran parte de los
que participaron en ella,
voluntaria o involuntariamente,
es que ha producido en ellos
una serie de síntomas
que algunos psiquiatras describen como
trastorno por estrés postraumático.
Estos síntomas que
afectan a los soldados,
sobrevivientes del trauma, de 3 formas.
Afectan sus acciones en el mundo,
sus percepciones
y sus experiencias sociales.
Uno de los síntomas del trastorno
por estrés postraumático es
"una constante movilización del cuerpo
y de la mente hacia el peligro mortal,
un potencial para desarrollar
violencia explosiva
como resultado de estar
constantemente alerta".
Todos conocen la sensación de
estar completamente alertas
cuando sienten que están en peligro.
Es algo que ocupa un enorme porcentaje
de los recursos del cuerpo.
Todo se concentra para
reaccionar de inmediato.
Esto puede presentarse en
todo tipo de dominios.
Puede pasar si están
concentrados en un videojuego
que requiere que den una
respuesta muy rápida
o si sienten que están en una
situación peligrosa.
Es una experiencia completa del cuerpo
que determina la relación con el mundo.
Imagínense estar completamente
alerta todo el tiempo.
Una consecuencia de estar
alerta de esa manera
es que la gente percibe las cosas
de la peor manera posible.
Si están en contra de los riesgos,
entonces cada vez que se
topen con un riesgo,
existe la posibilidad de que
consideren que se están enfrentando
al peor escenario.
Los soldados que padecen trastorno
por estrés postraumático
perciben las cosas a su alrededor
a través de sus mecanismos de
atención agudizados
que acompañan a su reacción inmediata
y las perciben como riesgos potenciales.
Las cosas que consideran
peligros potenciales
no son solo los objetos
triviales del mundo,
como un objeto ambiguo sobre una mesa
que puede parecer una pistola
o un inofensivo trozo de cartón,
sino que esto también pasa en sus
interacciones sociales.
Posiblemente el mayor precio que pagan,
y veremos por qué es así en
la clase del jueves,
es perder la posibilidad
de tener confianza en la sociedad.
Quiero mostrarles cómo puede pasar esto
en culturas enteras.
Las comunidades que están
sometidas por sus opositores
a ciertos tipos de terrorismo o
guerra de guerrillas
pierden la capacidad de
comportarse humanamente
hacia aquellos con quienes luchan.
Si la estrategia de tu enemigo
es traer bombas a tu país
usando ambulancias,
entonces te verás obligado a pensar
que las ambulancias son sospechosas.
Si, según describe Shay en
Achilles in Vietnam,
una estrategia común es
poner a un bebé
encima de una pila de
explosivos, te verás obligado,
debido a las acciones de tu enemigo,
a no ayudar a un niño necesitado.
Privar a tu enemigo
de su capacidad de comportarse
humanamente contigo
es una estrategia que produce un
ciclo sumamente desordenado.
Por su puesto,
la sensación de sentirse
acorralado sin otra opción,
llevaría a una persona a usar la
estrategia de usar las ambulancias
para transportar bombas y
así sucesivamente.
El orden que gobierna la
guerra convencional
es un reflejo de cierto tipo de
necesidad psicológica.
Y el desorden típico de una
guerra no convencional,
donde Vietnam es un ejemplo y
el terrorismo es otro,
es algo que produce en una
sociedad entera
algo similar al trastorno por
estrés postraumático
que Shay identifica en los soldados.
En los últimos 5 min. de la clase
quiero darles 2 ejemplos del
fenómeno que describe Shay
y después los relacionaré con
el reto de Glaucón.
La Iliada es una historia de
obsesión y de ira.
Y el pasaje inicial, que cita Shay,
del Libro I que les pedí
que leyeran para hoy,
es una expresión de la cólera
indignante que sintió Aquiles
ante la traición de las reglas
de honor de la guerra.
Esta es una cita de Aquiles
del Libro XVI
acerca de una situación previa:
"Solo este amargor corroe mi
corazón, cuando un hombre
ha privado de algo y ha
avergonzado a su igual,
al quitarle su premio
mediante el abuso de poder.
La mujer que los aqueos
eligieron para mí,
la gané con mi propia lanza.
Tomé por asalto y saqueé una
ciudad amurallada por ella,
después Agamenón me la arrebató
como si yo fuera un
bandolero ordinario".
Es una violación al código de honor.
Es una violación de las
reglas y expectativas
que Aquiles tenía al
entrar a la guerra.
"Tomé por asalto y saqueé una
ciudad amurallada por ella.
Me han privado de ella no por
las reglas de la guerra
sino por el abuso de poder".
Aquí hay un soldado de Vietnam
diciendo más de lo mismo.
Describe al "hombre punta",
que básicamente es el trabajo
que implica colocarse
al inicio de la línea de soldados
que tiene más posibilidades de
morir a causa de un explosivo.
Ser el "hombre punta" era un
trabajo sumamente peligroso.
La decisión de quién
debía hacer ese trabajo
no se hacía de forma justa.
Se hacía políticamente.
A algunos les tocaba.
A otros no.
Ciertas personas a la derecha
de ciertas personas".
Esta idea de que la distribución
de los riesgos no se apega
a las reglas sino a los
caprichos provoca un desorden.
Esto provoca, como ya lo dije en
la diapositiva pasada,
una especie de pérdida de la confianza,
un reconocimiento de que
objetos ordinarios,
como el bebé en la mina,
tienen un peligro potencial.
"Nada es lo que parece, todas
las certezas se licuan".
Y el segundo descubrimiento que los
soldados de Vietnam hicieron
es algo que discutiremos en el
contexto de un documento
que leeremos titulado "Suerte moral".
El descubrimiento de lo que uno es capaz
en determinadas circunstancias.
Dice un veterano:
"Es increíble lo que los humanos
pueden hacerse entre sí.
Nunca pensé, ni en millones de años,
que sería capaz de hacer algo así.
Nunca, nunca, nunca".
Aquí está la respuesta de Shay
y de Homero a Glaucón:
Estimado Glaucón, toma nota.
La preocupación que estos
soldados expresan
no es sobre lo que aparentaban.
No es sobre lo que se
percibe que hayan hecho.
De hecho, una de sus quejas es que
cuando volvieron a casa,
nadie escuchaba sus historias.
La preocupación de estos soldados es
acerca de lo que han hecho,
de lo que han sido y no de lo
que ha aparentado ser.
Es el ser, lo que son, el
caso intrínseco
lo que les preocupa.
Retomaremos este tema al inicio
de la siguiente clase
con la discusión de Milgram
y pasaremos a las lecturas de Epicteto
y a las versiones
contemporáneas análogas de
esto.